hi everyone it's true's news on the road
and today we are at Comic-Con here in
New York City and I've got the mother of
all co-pilots an icon of American Cinema
she's made 52 films and counting but it
all started with one blood curdling
scream it's Jamie Lee Curtis
buddy
buddy hello people so we're celebrating
Halloween ends the final chapter in the
franchise started by John Carpenter 44
years ago but I did love like and it's
actually your mom Janet Lee that when I
got to do scream was my big influence to
say I think what would be great about
kicking off we didn't know it would ever
be a franchise it was called scary movie
at the time and I just thought that
opening scene was like more harken back
to when a stranger calls and I was like
Janet Lee and psycho like when she
leaves the film so early and you lose
the star of the film all bets are off
that means like anyone is fair game in
the movie unlike Halloween where you
have been the ultimate reason why people
should survive because you don't want
them to go you want to see them go on
and on and on which is what you've done
with this franchise for how many years
now 44 44 which I mentioned in the end
of 44 years of Lori Strokes so is it
surreal to be at the end of the row you
know why it's beautiful because of
people like that you know the whole
reason I have a career through is
because of Lori Strode totally
everything in my life that's good I owe
to her and them and the truth of the
matter is my life is their life because
they have given
um the support and ongoing support of
Lori Strode for all these years and
because of her then of course you know
all the other things that have happened
in my life family kids Etc well speaking
of news you ready to hit the headlines
I'm ready first up the movie site we got
this covered says that horror fans think
that 2022 is a golden year for scary
movies we started the year with the
fifth installment of scream
um a movie close to my heart and then we
had a parade of spine tinglers nope
smile Barbarian and now we're putting
the bloody cherry on top with Halloween
ends Jamie the fans are going bananas
but like how do you say goodbye to
Laurie Strode I I am Lori Strode at this
point at 64 Lori strod and Jamie are
different when I played Lori when when
she was 17 and I was 19. that was a
character I loved it I got to dress
differently than I did it was an acting
part but by now the two have merged and
by the end of this 2022 film where Lori
has also had an opportunity to work
through a little bit of the trauma that
she never you know I still believe that
Lori Strode
went back to school November 2nd 1978.
like I think they gave her they gave her
a day off put a Band-Aid on her arm and
basically sent her back into the wild
and never did anything never talked
about it it was one of those things
where nobody ever talked about those
things I think she was shamed at school
she was the weird girl you know she had
survivor's guilt and obviously she just
never got to work out what happened
and so in the new movie we meet a woman
who almost smiles there's a moment
beginning the movie she smiles there's
literally a smile on her face because
she although she is not consumed by the
grief of the loss of Karen she is
walking side by side with it it's there
it's always going to be there you don't
get over the loss of a child but she's
moving forward and I think it's just a
good place I love how much you love your
granddaughter too and taste of your
daughter that the connection is still
seeming and by the way the same it's
real with Andy matichek the actress and
Judy Greer I I they you know we are
Stroud strong I mean we are Strode
strong well also in the end of Halloween
ends which I don't want to give anything
away but you are taking real ownership
of the story
well it's a sad ending and you know the
the the truth is violence and and loss
is incredibly sad and affects everybody
this movie is about how it has affected
the entire town of haddenfield and
they've actually turned against Lori the
victim herself they have victim shamed
and it's it's sad that we do that and as
as a society
um we're seeing it kind of everywhere
and I I think it's as much a metaphor of
where we are I think in 30 years you'll
look back on the David Gordon green
movies and think that he was a genius I
think he's a genius too I really do okay
well next from horror to Heroes
um some news about apparently your pal
John Stamos so movie web reports that
John wants to be in a Marvel movie talk
about Comic-Con he says that no one is
offered but if they did he'd do it in
two seconds John was in Scream Queens
with you
um what would be a good super power for
John wow
is there a really handsome Marvel
character because John Stamos is just
drop it handsome I think there are kind
of a lot of hot guys are there hot
Marvels
you Marvel at these Marvels there's a
Corral of studs absolutely I I would I
would make him
I would make him a but I would then make
him mean I think what's also would be
fun is to like flip it and make him not
because he's already a superhero the
truth of the matter is who John is is a
superhero he couldn't love life more
he's couldn't love his kid more yeah
like he loves Being John so you want to
see him be the bad guy I do yeah I would
like to see him
but I'd like him to still be a really
hot bad guy really nasty when a guy is
hot and bad I mean that's just the
Catalyst for why so many women have made
poor choices in relationships all right
our next story this is some great news
from Goodwill NPR reports they are
taking their Thrifty Treasures online at
goodwillfines.com now you can shop over
a hundred thousand items from home and
some think that this could double store
Revenue which is a huge deal because it
all goes back into Goodwills Community
work and they've helped over a million
people people find jobs plus they've
saved over 9 billion pounds of stuff
from a landfill Jamie are you a Goodwill
girl on The Daily I drop off a bag of
Goodwill oh really on The Daily oh my
God then this story I want to end up
with nothing I'm I'm the divestor I am
constantly brooming old ideas from my
closet from my house I'm going to end up
with one black shirt one black pair of
pants and be a minimalist and be Zen and
happy I am such a Goodwill fanatic I'm
been a lifelong thrifter but I want to
be you but I'm a hoarder okay next up
when a college professor noticed her
students were coming in more stressed
than ever she developed a new course to
teach them how to do nothing time
reports it's officially the most popular
class at Lawrence University Professor
Constance cassar says that students
realize that they need to actually learn
how to slow down the course includes
lessons on meditation better sleep
habits mindful walking and how to be
bored and as you might guess this class
is a no cell phone zone so Jamie what's
your favorite way to decompress
I am decompressed I'm just I'm I'm my
normal life I'm
I'm a fairly decompressed person I have
a pet my dog I walk my dog Rooney but if
you were to like have to step into this
teacher's shoes and substitute for one
day because she's out sick and you want
to take over the class what would be a
suggestion as a decompressed person
that's a tip for them probably music
I would just probably
say we're just going to listen to music
all day that's what we're going to do
we're just gonna you can lay down you
can sit up you can walk around just
music I love it that's the perfect
perfect suggestion maybe you have Bette
Midler sing something to us I was
watching Hocus Pocus today with her with
my girls and I just brought our old
record player down and put all the
records out so that they can just play
with me right now her voice
drops me it's the best no her voice
drops me to the ground well I'd like to
see that
[Music]